wait wait
i'd get out of here
warden back to new rockstars we just got
a new look into the sony venomverse with
its latest installment venom let there
be carnage we saw a new symbiote threat
with some fresh daddy issues and
possibly the seed for the continuation
of the family line with toxin and now
that venom is out of san francisco it
looks like the lethal protector has
found himself a new target a new tasty
target
this is inside marvel hour after show
for sony's latest cinematic release that
exists in a nearby universe to the mcu
venom let there be carnage my name is mt
and we're going to talk about some of
the biggest revelations and burning
questions left over from the film and
discussing this all with me today is my
brother off-screen producer brandon
what's going on
hello mt i've got 80 billion light years
of hive knowledge in my head and i can't
wait to talk about venom ii
a lot of light years that's a lot of
light years buddy a lot knowledge you
can get a free lamborghini from that new
lamborghini anyway before we dive into
our questions left over from the film
let's do a quick blog summary shall we
because we begin in the year 1996. four
years after i was born so you know
don't age me empty don't age me
but yes we begin in 1996 where we first
meet a young cletus cassidy and francis
barrison who have pledged their love for
each other while serving time in a
mental institution like everyone else
does i mean if you've killed if you've
killed your family and you're stuck at a
mental institution you might as well
find some love ain't no one's gonna show
up for the wedding anyways but francis
has incredible powers that are growing
beyond her control and as she's being
taken away she makes one final escape
attempt using her shrieking powers only
to be shot in the eye by a young cop
named mulligan and fast forward to
present day where eddie brock is trying
to get his journalism career back on
track after he messed it up in the first
movie but now you know things are
getting better for him and he's the only
one cletus cassidy will even talk to you
as he wastes away on death row and venom
waits impatiently inside of eddie
spending a lot of time eating chocolate
and chicken to fulfill his need for
brains because
you know it's really real chocolate and
brains have like that one thing in
common and venom of course wants to be
the hero saving the day and eating bad
guys because you know why not he's
what's what he does he what is what he
does best and you can't trust the prison
system you got to eat the bad guys
right
it's more efficient on one of his trips
to visit cletus venom notices all the
cryptic writing on cletus's cell wall
and he later uses his impeccable memory
and drawing skills to show eddie what it
means i mean i love the fast drawing
like serious like venom ross in this
like yeah but it's like a cad
machine just drawing it out really fast
uh you're too young for that
happy little trees
and what he finds are clues to cle to
more of cletus's victims and after eddie
shares this information with the cops
the public is out for justice and the
governor of california reinstitutes the
death penalty and now cletus is gonna
die but before he officially die he
wants to talk to eddie one last time
because he thinks something is up with
old eddie brock and during this last
interview he bites eddie and gets a
taste of his blood uh and as well as the
symbiote that's inside it's no blood
he's ever tasted before uh and when it's
finally time for cletus's execution the
symbiote is now inside of him and makes
itself known it's carnage baby carnage
baby
cletus breaks out of san quentin but not
before killing a bunch of guards uh he
gets a glow up because he finds a guy
whose outfit he really likes and bites
his head off uh he gets a new car
uh and carnage and then he carnage hacks
the internet with his little red fingers
i know that was so weird i was like you
can do that that's kind of a very
convenient power but why not why not and
he finds out that his long lost love
francis is still alive uh he breaks her
out of the secretive ravencroft facility
uh but when she uses her shrieking
powers to aid in the escape uh carnage
is not too happy about it and a little
rude oh no
yeah because those symbiotes do not like
sound at all they don't like it and uh
yeah sounding fire sound and fire get in
the middle of their relationship and get
a little testy there
um that's the problem with a
three-person relationship mt someone's
gonna be unhappy at some point right you
know whenever i hear about those poly
relationships i'm like hey man do what
you got to do but that sounds a little
bit messy to me
but of course meanwhile eddie and venom
are on a break and venom goes host
hopping and you know sort of super
messed up because i'm pretty sure a lot
of those people died it kills a few
innocent people along the way maybe
right he's just like hey i just want to
go to a party just like this
a human uber or something like that i
don't know
but yes venom goes host hopping does
some partying but winds up back at mrs
chen's shop because no one is as good as
eddie's body i mean have you seen tom
hardy good god
specimen um but with the help of anne
eddie and venom are you reunited but it
isn't long before she's kidnapped by
shriek along with detective mulligan to
lure eddie and venom to carnage so that
he can kill his daddy a lot of people
have daddy issues
movies i don't know this film's all
about daddy's issues it's all about
daddy issues all the time and of course
an epic battle occurs in a cathedral and
both shriek and carnage are ultimately
defeated and venom devours carnage like
every dad should i guess just devour
your child just kidding don't eat your
babies please um i mean if they're
murderous
if they're murderous symbiotes eat your
baby yes but otherwise let them be venom
devours carnage and bites off cletus's
head for good measure because you gotta
be safe you never know with crazy people
um and detective mulligan survives the
encounter but is he the same man
probably not
he got really messed up he he definitely
needs at least a little bit of a you
know chiropractor
stuff
because uh his back doesn't seem like
he's doing too good um and knowing that
the police will be on the hunt for eddie
and venom they escaped san francisco for
a tropical paradise in the post-credits
scene venom lets eddie in on a little
bit of the billions of years of
collective knowledge of his alien hive
mind just before they are pulled into a
different universe a universe with a
very familiar face tom holland who will
get a little nibble by venom probably in
a future film which i'm very excited to
taste he wants a taste but before we get
into all that our merch partners at epic
hero shop just dropped a shirt inspired
by venom let there be carnage and this
shirt is called symbiotic chaos and
features the epic struggle between our
chaotic black and red alien symbiotes
it's a really cool design that won't be
available in this universe for long so
please be sure to grab one before
they're all gone so check out all the
awesome gear and apparel including the
venom inspired shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com it's a great way
to support the channel and to show your
passion for all things nerdy but before
we continue we do want to thank adam and
eve for sponsoring this video as the
weather cools off a lot of us are going
to shift from outdoor activities to more
indoor activities in the coming months
well our friends at adam and eve are
here to help with one of our most fun
indoor activities and i'm not talking
about scrabble y'all though they
definitely sell some things that could
make scrabble more exciting that's what
i'm saying you know
have you ever played scrabble with your
clothes off brandon it's pretty fun a
little strip scrabble hello um they also
sell some clothing that could definitely
be repurposed for a halloween costume if
you're looking to raise some eyebrows
this october 31st if you know what i'm
saying i mean a little a little lady
venom always raises my eyebrows a little
bit right
[Laughter]
adamandeve.com is offering 50 off just
about any item and plus free shipping on
your entire order so what do you have to
do to get your 50 off one item and free
shipping it's not really that hard just
go to adamandeve.com and select any one
item and it could be an adventurous new
toy or anything you think can make your
indoor time a little bit more fun this
fall so just enter code marvel at
checkout and you'll get 50 off almost
any item so go to adamandeve.com today
select one item and get 50 off including
free shipping when you enter code marvel
that is m-a-r-v-e-l-marvel
adam and eve dot com so brandon i got a
question for you so after that insane
mid-credits sequence it looks like our
favorite symbiote is now in the marvel
cinematic universe what do you think
this means going forward brandon oh i
mean this
it's crazy like
this is everything we've been like
hoping for right and kind of been
wondering for a while like how close is
the venomverse to the mcu right uh and
it looks like they're not taking the
whole thing they're just taking our
little boy venom and plucking them out
but
i mean i think the craziest thing is
you know we get to we've seen the
trailer for spider-man no way home we
know there's this spell that doctor
strange maybe not dr strange does uh and
then at the end you know we see like the
green goblins pumpkin bomb and we see
doc ock from the raimi verse
so
we kind of get like a little glimpse of
what it looks like on the other side of
that spell right because uh
you know venom and eddie are taken the
room changes around them so they're
still in the same place but just in a
different timeline or a different
universe which i think is like crazy uh
right that's like that's totally nuts it
really blew my mind i was like oh this
is this kind of is like a sneak peek
into what we're gonna see in the next
movie or maybe never even see in doctor
strange we may we are in a spider-man we
might not see the other side uh what it
looks like for the villains who get
brought into the mcu like that yeah and
like it's i find it really striking that
like the entire universe changed around
venom and eddie but they seem to retain
the memories of the past universe
whereas that guy was like what are you
doing in my room like what is this like
you're not supposed to be here yeah yeah
so like it kind of makes me wonder
whether or not that like you know that
primordial or like that really old you
know connection that you know venom has
to his you know past and like you know
the the the klintar race being like the
super old race i wonder if that has to
do with you know eddie remembering their
memories because like he is this being
that sort of existed sort of pre-big
bang right like it does this does this
mean that the venom universe and the mcu
merged into one universe like is or like
are we
like experiencing this weird like all
right like just eddie and venom just got
i don't know transported to the mcu and
only them i think i think your latter
point is more right empty like i think
this is just like a fun crossover it's
gonna be like a fun crossover episode
and depending on what happens in
spider-man no way home eddie and venom
might find a way home and might find
their way back to
uh their own universe uh towards the end
but what is crazy empty is how did venom
like right away
know
who or what spider-man was and know that
that should be a target like what are
your thoughts on that
i think that you know because they were
watching the news and because peter
parker of course with the the events of
spider-man far from home is a criminal
um venom is like hey this is uh that's a
criminal and he looks pretty good he
looks like a strong profile criminal
yeah and like you know i'm sure he's
hearing with the audios like oh the hero
spider-man and like you know
like oh he uses strength to kill
mysterio and all this stuff he was like
hmm that guy's pretty strong i don't
know why i'm doing a venomous brush i
like your voice
he looks delicious
he could maybe even be a better match
than eddie who knows
are we going to see black suit
spider-man again i mean i feel like you
can't put venom in a spider-man movie
without giving us black suit spider-man
because time figures need to be sold
brian action figures need to be sold and
we haven't had a black suit spider-man
in the trailer for spider-man no way at
home he's wearing that black suit with
kind of like a little bit of gold trim
on it like right i don't know could that
have been
that's definitely his uh i think that's
his doctor strange inspired suit i think
that's his like multiverse traveling
suit maybe i don't know that could be
the seeds because we got night monkey in
the
far from home and now we got this black
suit so and then we can vent him in the
next one so who knows
we're just graduating black suits slowly
until we get the real uh evil black suit
i mean that's that's a great point empty
that you were making that like
the thing they see on the news is jay
jonah jamison saying like this is a bad
guy this is the number one menace this
is the problem and venom who's like made
it clear in this movie that he wants to
be
you know the lethal protector he wants
to be the like
the hero he wants to eat the bad guys in
like if this is the number one bad guy
like that's who he wants to go after
um i also think that you know right when
that moment happens you know venom is
describing oh i i'm plugged into this
hive mind and we get all the knowledge
from all the symbiotes from throughout
time and he even says something like uh
across like our knowledge of of the
universes or across the universes almost
that like the symbiotes are aware that
there are multiple universes and i'm
wondering in that moment that they get
plucked out of the sony venomverse and
put into the mcu if venom is immediately
tied into whatever symbiotic hive mind
exists there
and those symbiotes are aware of
spider-man somehow are aware of peter
parker and he immediately is like oh
yeah this is the one i know who this is
and eddie's just kind of catching up
slowly but like venom right away is like
oh i know what's going on right away
right now i'm here let's do it uh and
maybe there are already symbiotes are
aware of spider-man uh maybe nulls out
there unaware of spider-man i i don't
know but like yes oh this movie 100
teases no like that's the only thing
that like that i was most excited about
while leaving this movie i was like oh
my god he mentioned the billions of
years of high knowledge and like we're
getting into like this weird like you
know multiverses and like the big bang
and the initial singularity and all that
stuff so like we're definitely going to
see null in the future that is
something that i am most confident about
like put that like i'm putting put
myself on the record okay like we're
going to see null
in the future of the sony venomverse
like there's no way that we're not going
to but no like what you said with um the
the universe is in like um the hive
minds like crossing across universes we
have seen a uh a symbiote fight of
spider-man in spider-man 3 in the rainy
trilogy so like if that little
multiverse thing didn't happen at the
end of venom i feel like tom hardy was
probably going to witness the events of
spider-man 3 because that symbiote
was there and was probably connected to
the hive mind as well so he's like oh
shoot that's what he was doing before he
died
but yeah no this i feel like there's
probably going to be some link between
maybe like the the the venom
the the klyntar race and maybe like the
spider totem connection that is in the
spider-verse comics because okay all the
spider-man are connected and it seems
like all the venoms are connected
throughout universes as well because we
do have the venomverse comics in the
comics where they have this weird uh
like series where like it's like they're
different venoms from different
universes like because they have to you
know capitalize on the spider verse
stuff of course of course um but yeah no
there is a venomverse and
i think would they just tease it in this
video so i mean this movie so i'm very
excited yeah it was pretty wild stuff
because you know they have not made any
hints that this crossover was gonna
happen anytime soon and it seemed like
you know sony and marvel have kind of
been like you know in their separate
camps and doing their thing and sharing
spider-man a little bit but it's been
very testy and it's been you know it's
played out interesting in the news so
this was just kind of a shock and it
kind of came out of nowhere and it was
like okay
this will be exciting and i i'm very
excited to see
you know
venom appear in uh spiderman no way home
and what that means and
is this gonna push
venom to more of a bad guy role or more
of a good guy role i i don't know you
know the venom has been our our
protagonist in these films for lack of a
better word because he's still kind of
bad he's still eating people
uh you know even if they are criminals
they deserve their day in court you
don't just deserve to get your head
bitten off for mugging somebody and also
like you said i don't know brandon
that's uh seems like a controversial
statement uh you know an eye for an eye
got brought up in this movie uh
but like venom like you said like venom
like host hopping
and killing these these people he's
hopping really messed up it's very
messed up
it's it's some dark stuff when you
really think about it um
because i was you know i was thinking
like in the first venom movie we did see
a lot of people die
uh you know the the homeless woman that
eddie knew and you know tried to rescue
from the life foundation she passed away
like all those homeless test subjects
died we see jenny slate's character die
even though she was a part of it so
she's kind of evil she tried to stop it
she was scared her children were
threatened you know so you know we were
going through this movie and i was like
oh there's not as much innocent death in
this one until like he started
hosnapping so
this next level of venom
venom in the light of the mcu will be
very interesting because i think he's
definitely on the bad side even if his
intentions deep down are maybe good he's
he's gonna be a villain you know i think
he's gonna be put on the bad side we'll
see if he helps spider-man or just tries
to eat him i don't know
well i have a question for you brandon
because like with venom of course we
talked about the whole black suit thing
is there a chance that we could see
venom duplicate himself like he did in
this last movie with peter and so like
peter has his own version of venom after
you know fighting with eddie and he's
like so and like that's where his
struggle goes in after
um no way home it's like all right now i
have a piece of venom with me and like
eddie has his venom and like now i have
like my best oh like a tongue venom
almost another almost another child of
venom that like goes into it oh okay
that
i would love for a little piece of venom
to stick around if he even if he gets
put back in his own universe that's fine
but let's leave a little bit in the mcu
you know we'd love to see some symbiote
action especially if noah's going to
show up we need we need we need to have
the symbiote exactly and like i feel
like because venom is this new anti-hero
character sony probably doesn't want
spider-man to be like oh no venom is the
super evil guy like they kind of want to
separate like the venom from the movies
with like whatever venom that peter is
going to struggle with in his movies
because you know that is supposed to be
his like bad guy like he's supposed to
struggle with his you know his very
angry and evil dark part of himself
right so like i wonder if they're just
gonna make a completely new venom
because i feel like that makes the most
sense with because they do want to make
a venom 3 with a sympathetic venom so i
feel like that's the
and that's what i do i would also love a
venom to stick around because i want the
thunderbolts man i want that thunderbolt
so bad
and venom in the thunderbolts is great
he's like a great character to happen
he's perfect literally val would go
straight up to eddie you'd be like hey
where did you come from you don't care
don't come join my team you're working
for me you're done being a journalist
buddy i mean if they're gonna have
abomination in the thunderbolts i think
it's tough because
venom and abomination kind of feel the
same role you know they're the tanks
right they're the big tough guys they're
the muscle so i don't know if you can
have both but i love the run on the
comics when venom is in the thunderbolts
it's so much fun uh it's fun to have
this character who you gotta feed people
to every now and then uh but he's
fighting on the good side
uh it's a lot of fun i have one other
question about this for you empty
uh so when they when they hop over and
they see jay jonah jameson do you think
there is a jade jonah jameson in the
sony venomverse
like eddie works for the daily bugle you
know we saw him writing for the daily
bugle and in the first movie he talks
about you know he was in new york and
got kicked out of got driven out of new
york was there a jay jonah jameson in
his universe do you think they're
familiar with that character like right
off the bat um absolutely uh this is the
whole jay jonah jameson verse that's the
whole sony he's the backbone of the
entire sony sony cinematic universe he's
the one honestly i would really love if
there was really a jonah jameson do you
think it's also jk simmons or they'll
put like a different character i mean
you've got to leave it has to be jk
simmons please jk simmons in every
universe different hairstyles
i want a moe mohawk
simmons
it's got a mullet maybe like something
like that here's another question that
wasn't really exactly entered in this
movie
how the hell did shriek get her powers
because disorder's like oh here's
cletus's girlfriend she has powers
that's it like is she is she a mutant
i mean it seems like she's
it's definitely trending towards mutant
right because she's a young woman whose
powers are like coming to fruition we
don't really know why she's locked up in
this institution i assume because she's
used her powers and maybe hurt somebody
or killed somebody right uh and she says
like my powers are getting stronger and
that's why they're gonna move her to a
new facility you know they have this
whole secretive ravencroft facility
where even
uh didn't detective mulligan say
something like this place no one knew it
existed or something like it was hidden
away from him like he thought he killed
that girl yeah yeah so like he was like
whoa
what is this place and why is she alive
so we have this mysterious facility it's
like off the grid it's ostensibly not a
government agency it doesn't seem like
or if it is it's way above what the sfpd
knows i saw some kids naruto running to
ravencroft because they thought it was
area 50 trying to break them out that
was very interesting
trying to break them out
so i mean and we know that sony just has
the rights to the spider-man they don't
have the rights to the x-men and mutants
and all that and that was fox and now uh
marvel's pulled that back in disney's
got that now he's sucking them in
wallet money
so but it was just mysterious they kind
of no one seemed to question why this
woman was able to do these things
um so are there like more mutants in the
venomverse that are is it more common
there to have people with powers like it
didn't seem like that shocking to
anybody like no one you know no one off
to the side was like whoa did that lady
just like scream at a helicopter like
what happened i don't understand yeah
and they have this facility built up
they had that mysterious woman who was
running the facility who died i thought
she would immediately she died
immediately right i thought they were
setting her up for like venom three it's
like we have all these superheroes here
we have all these uh they had that
siegfried guy who they mentioned my name
is siegfried i couldn't i couldn't
establish who he was i looked around a
little bit maybe look around some more i
don't i don't know if he was another
powered individual why he was locked up
in there but yeah it does seem like she
might be a mutant right there they
didn't give us any backstory of like
she's you know as a kid got some
chemicals splashed on her or anything
like that um this seems to be the first
example of like just a straight up
person with powers
that are unexplained yeah this could
very much be like the mcu's first mute
because in the comics she is a mutant i
mean other than in black widow we did
have ursa major who was exactly a mutant
right this is like a
cousin of the mcu right like yes
i wish they had said the word i mean
that would have i would have jumped up
out of my seat if someone said the word
mutant like lock up this muty i would
have been jumping
baby uh luck of this mutant from the
marvel comics right now
certified newton like if just a computer
screen had been like you know uh francis
mutant uh would have been you would have
been would have been really great um
maybe like the mcu is the only universe
that doesn't have mutants yet and they
exist in every other one and whatever
you know breaking down of the multiverse
between you know
uh spider-man norway home and the loki
and the tva and what if and whatever
uh scarlet witch is up to is just gonna
bring them all in somehow let's get them
go i mean we are just waiting for these
mutants what the hell happened to
detective mulligan anyway like
will we be seeing toxin in venom three i
mean i think they're certainly setting
that up right mt uh
for those of you who don't know toxin is
yet another symbiote in the symbiote
universe um but his grandson toxin
grandson yeah toxin is
in the comics he was like the offspring
of carnage who carnage also in the
comics end of the movie was the
offspring of venom um and toxin is
supposed to be the thousand the one
thousandth offspring in the the venom
line
you know so it's like you won one of
those uh fake uh things on the internet
you're the 1000th visitor oh yeah yeah
because he's the 1000th one he's
supposed to be like the most powerful
like carnage is more powerful than venom
but now toxin is supposed to be more
powerful than carnage and venom so i
think they're definitely setting that up
you know we saw his eyes glow blue
and he said monsters
monsters unleashed
well like so like you did mention that
like you know the venom might have to
fight another symbiote in venom three
but like does that really have to be the
case because he did fight riot in venom
one and we did fight carnage and venom
too so like could it be possible that we
could see toxin and venom team up oh
venom three against a bigger threat like
maybe a no because like mulligan and
eddie seem to have like this weird like
team-up relationship at the end of the
movie and mulligan is not entirely a bad
dude he just wanted credit for the the
whole cletus stuff because at the
beginning yeah you know mulligan he's
just a cop he's trying to do his best
and he's he's working with what he's got
he's only has the resources of the
police department and he has to fight
alien symbiotes i mean it's gonna be
tough it's gonna be tough
for some reason they don't respect his
badge i don't know why aliens are so
rude it was kind of weird that he kept
going around and being like
why does cletus make everyone think they
see monsters it's like because he turned
into a giant monster i mean do they not
have video cameras at the present like
did nobody see what happened like i'm
totally seriously like at least one
camera should have caught that like he
made a carnage tornado he made a tornado
no one saw this literally that was the
most wild part of the movie i was like
wow why don't you just pull that out
every time yeah two tornadoes all the
time dude
like you could have tornado that entire
chapel in like
that whole third act would have been
over very quickly one thing that was
very interesting is like in the comics
you know toxin does take over a police
officer named patrick mulligan uh
that's the same but also initially when
toxin takes over mulligan they
impersonate spider-man for a little bit
they oh that's right the symbiote kind
of makes this uh the suit looks like a
spider-man suit like red and blue i
think uh
and so that
if we aren't gonna introduce spider-man
even if it's another universe
maybe this guy becomes the spider-man of
this universe or there is a spider-man
in the sony venomverse and that could be
part of it too is like him trying to be
a good guy like he he is a cop so he's
like maybe he wants to continue being a
good guy he knows now he knows about
alien symbiotes so he's gonna be like
i'm gonna suit up and i'm gonna take
this on i'm gonna do what my badge never
let me do and i'm gonna go out there and
i'm gonna fight with this with this
toxin ability uh but ultimately he'll
probably
lean back that's a good let's get
brandon on the venom three writing team
right now
he'll be next to tom hardy we'll figure
this thing out
so do you think carnage is 100
dead do you think venom meaning him and
biting off cletus's head that was enough
to get rid of carnage that's the
question that's the question with
symbiotes because like are they really
really dead because like in um in venom
one didn't we see riot sort of merge
with um with venom for a little bit
venom and eddie yeah when they were
fighting uh yeah when they were fighting
on this in the spaceship and there was
all the noise it created like a lot of
stat and i think at one point they did
kind of like goop up together uh shout
out to gwyneth paltrow
yeah gwyneth goop
and if toxin is an offspring of carnage
then there could be some carnage left
somewhere i you know who knows the rules
with these symbiotes uh
they can do whatever they want they're
crazy they're crazy little creatures we
don't know if cletus wrote with the
cardinal symbiote the same way that
venom drew with the venom symbiote at
the beginning of the movie and like we
don't know
what the
long-term effects of like having like a
piece of symbiote on a piece of paper
could mean like maybe you could just
grow another symbiote from that little
bit left behind that's a great point if
there was some blood left over also when
venom's eating carnage it's very sloppy
and sticky all over it doesn't look like
he gets it all in his mouth so there
could be a little mess eater squidgle
squirting around down there
existing probably maybe the uh maybe the
pastor is now carnage maybe i think they
bit his head off i don't it's wait did
the pastor die
it was all very messy you know it's
pg-13 so they show every head biting off
screen so you have to kind of like it's
implied imagine it well finally brandon
one of the biggest questions leaving
this film is how old is venom exactly
because he seems pretty damn old that's
a great question empty because like he
he does mention you know like all the
knowledge but i i agree i think that's
like a hive mind thing it's like
everyone gets all the knowledge together
you know in the first movie when they
came when they were on they were taking
off the comment you know he mentioned
that like riot was like the boss right
he was the one in charge so i assume he
was like maybe the older the elder
symbiote that was taken off that comet
um and he does say you know one thing
they brought up in the first one was
like i gotta protect earth from like all
the symbiotes that could come and do
damage
but that makes me think he's like a
younger version of a symbiote now we
don't know how long the symbiotes live
for you know young to them might be a
few thousand years like you look like
thor who's like five thousand years old
or whatever
so young is is relative um but it does
seem like venom has like that adolescent
streak to him where he's very altruistic
he thinks he can do good but he doesn't
always think things through all the way
doesn't think through the consequences
of his actions he's very impulsive so i
think he's like a younger guy i think he
younger symbiote guy uh he's a you know
he's got that young streak to him so
whether that means he's 15 years old or
15 000 years old i can't say but i think
in the timeline of of symbiotes i think
he's on the younger side because he's
got that youthful energy he's got that
altruism uh and he doesn't think through
his actions all the time what do you
think i'm team i'd like to think that
venom was klyntar's version of uh dennis
the menace and uh riot was mr wilson
he's like where's dennis he's just
trying to get dennis the menace off this
planet he's like we just need to find
dennis he's a menace he didn't bring him
back to clinton
but no i think that you know i think
that you probably are right here and
ryan had a lot more experience he was a
lot more you know dedicated to his
planet's cause like sort of like zod in
man of steel it's like all right we want
to you know expand our empire sort of or
just
grow more and so whereas venom is more
like you know your kalel it's like all
right i don't want to
be part of this group of people that are
just and like i'm a loser there
anyway and like i'm a little bit more
compassionate than my
um my brothers over there so i'm going
to be a hero over here yeah he wants to
go out he wants to party he wants to
live life like he's on in the first one
he's on earth for like a couple days and
he's like i love it i want to stay let's
save this baby he's like not so bad
that's bad i like it here i do love that
eddie constantly calls venom's planet
mingmong or whatever
that makes me laugh the most
i just wanna i wanna like you know in
the middle of venom three right they cut
to space and you see a planet and the
little title card says mingmong
and i hope we meet venom's mom so we can
meet his ming my mom
[Laughter]
well
that is it for this special episode of
inside marvel i want to thank brandon
for joining me this episode you can
follow him at grindenberric on twitter
and you can follow me at mastertainment
if you want to see me tweet some weird
and of course please follow new
rockstars wherever we are especially on
twitter at new rockstars or on youtube
and when you do on youtube please hit
that notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and please of course hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can see all of
our great merch options including that
new venom shirt but anyway thank you
guys so much for watching we love you
and goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
you